le casse de l'année donc le meilleur
cash regardez les noms dont le trophée
du meilleur clash kelly d'une vie et
agathe au cou
quand on met un décolleté ou cours
montre ses fesses on sait très bien
pertinemment quoi on n'est pas d'accord
avec les réseaux sociaux mais on sait
que ça va arriver
non
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
géraldine maillet et agathe au promu
moi ça m'énerve un peu si tu veux que on
déresponsabilise et sous prétexte qu'on
est jeunes on peut écrire tout et
n'importe quoi ensuite deuxième ans t'as
dit je me suis renseigné alors c'est
quoi tes élise lucet de tpm p est ce que
tu as fait vraiment une enquête
et enfin troisième chose tu pars
beaucoup des réseaux sociaux et tu dis
oui mais les réseaux sociaux c'est
n'importe quoi enfin vraiment eu des
combats ni hier tu les a condamnés ces
réseaux sociaux mais tu es aussi une
créature des réseaux sociaux et bien sûr
voilà pour les tweets que tu as fait
qu'ils étaient aussi abjecte et ignoble
effectivement on pourrait dire pourquoi
à gâteaux pour est athée pmp
benjamin castaldi est un gâteau proulx
je trouve que on a raconté les des
inepties inepties sur l'ineptie dont
contre l' amalgame d'isabelle qui n'a
pas été compris entre benjamin castaldi
excuse moi qui relaie défectueuse de la
fachosphère en parlant d' apologie au
terrorisme ou en traitant des proxys en
prêtant si en prêtant une proximité non
tu va retirer tout de suite en prêtant
une attention je ne parle pas là entrée
te colle alors je peux donc pas turquie
a tout de suite
malheureusement c'est les sources déjà
mains moites bazar est fashion alors je
n'en fais pas déconner non plus faire de
quoi c'est la fachosphère tshabalala
vous allez loin
[Musique]
en tout cas en tout cas ce qui est sûr
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il y aura un
gâteau coup ça c'est certain
voilà du coup j'ai un trophée joe diop
bien sûr vous aurez trouvé ça c'est sûr
et certain temps déjà mais qui ont fait
bouffer le partager avec qui alors je
vais vous dire je crois qu'on a choisi
le clash dans la longueur en fait un
voilà je vous dis est bon pour nous les
deux gagnantes sont bien entendu et le
gagnant est
kelly du nord il y ait un gâteau proulx
qualité de bélie et agathe au prompt à
bientôt pour voilà votre trophée mais
justement ce soir et la qualif je vous
en donne la merci merci